this was asked by someone who I think
was getting married what would be the
most interesting metal to make a ring
from I suppose if you were getting
married one of the most interesting
metals would be the magnetic alloy an
interesting metal for ring you probably
couldn't use iron because that might
rust or platinum and gold are often used
says copper so can't be any of those I
think it would have to be all sorry gold
diamonds are a girl's best friends and
I'll show some diamonds in there you
know what I would like I would like to
have some kind of I know like a a ring
that's in case is mercury I suppose
Koren novel ring would be made of
mercury so it's like something like a
strong glass or something like that you
know but obviously it's got to be
delicate to fit on your finger but say
that the mercury will just constantly
slosh around but you'd really have to
cool it down
to keep it on your finger that would
make the most interesting saying and
also you know it's it's quite risky
wearing it isn't it because any time if
it breaks oh you can just cover yourself
in mercury
maybe not the best idea I don't know
[Music]
interesting metal interesting goodness I
don't know it a nians pretty low light
very stiff what about a cesium ring
everybody ready
Platinum would be quite nice but ghouls
also nice that mean interesting no I
don't know maybe they just standard what
be most interesting so the melting point
of gallium is quite close to the body
temperature isn't it so if you could
make a ring out of gallium why do you
normal body temperature the ring would
probably sit quite nicely on your finger
because it's called by the environment
but if you were to get like hot and
perhaps feverish then the ring of
probably south melt so that would be
quite interesting I don't know oh yeah I
don't know I'd like to see just how
heavy a lad ring would be imagine if a
couple had magnetic rings then when they
held hands they'd stick together well I
think business would be good because I
remember the bismuth videos and it looks
very pretty I don't know wedding rings a
really special on there you know it's
what matters to you and it's the metal
that you associate with the person you
want to be with a carbon fiber that's
not metal as it though titanium I don't
know be expensive I think just go with
gold it's it's pretty good my ring my
wedding ring is made out of um it's made
out of Welsh gold so obviously because
of the Welsh connection so my wife and I
have got matching Welsh gold wedding
rings well Welsh gold is no different
the gold that's made anywhere else you
know perhaps Ethiopia or or mined in
South Africa but I suppose what makes it
Welsh gold is where it was mined and it
was mined in a in a small Valley in
North Wales so it's quite close to my
home and quite close to to my family
links